have you seen Toy Story 4 yeah did you
like Toy Story 4 I did really liked it I
didn't like it as much as the first and
second one did you know that there's a
lot of things that actually required
censorship in Toy Story 4 Ashley no like
what Gregory like a lot of unnecessary
stuff we're gonna do a special try not
to laugh unnecessary censorship of Toy
Story 4
I don't think Ashley's ever seen one of
these kind of videos I don't think so
let's see yes you're we're hosts this is
how Greg can actually talk every all
right oh my god woman I won't have all
try not to laughs I find these doll like
really the hardest to not laugh at yeah
okay let's see let's see Greg fallen in
Japan oh by the way
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
because who do you think it is
well what's your job right now it's to
make sure you do yours No
[Music]
[Music]
haha that's an unnecessary censorship
for you I liked it that's so funny I've
never seen that before
oh man I've seen some of these by myself
ah that's good stuff it makes it it
makes him I feel like the funniest ones
was what was her name like the little
doll big bill on one Gaby Gaby yeah yeah
I feel like hers were the funniest
because she was like got such a sweet
little face and voice so yeah for some
reason I love how it always changes the
context the stories these unnecessary
censorships it does just a bit it makes
it seem like it's motivated by people
trying to give ladies than the one with
what he when he was like no she
literally yeah yeah oh man you know but
you're a kid you do have toys and you do
try to make them do stuff sometimes did
you did you did it you are like just
have this weird fantasy when I was
younger
have you seen Indian in the cup board
cupboard aha okay so if you guys ever
seen Indian the cupboard this guy gets a
cupboard you put a toy in it and it
totally comes to life when ya lock it
open it toy comes to life okay he's a
fantasy of shrinking down to a little
boy like even tinier fancy down to a
tiny little being and then bringing the
Barbie doll life and doing that Barbie
Wow
I think we all learned something here
today I play with my toys
do they do this for only animated movies
no it is like Avengers movies and a
whole bunch of films oh yeah I know I'm
gonna feel plane right now
yeah they're really funny guy your
boyfriend will love them give us some
inspiration all right guys that was so
funny subscribe to ninja Panna subscribe
to the real rejects click bells follow
Ashley on Instagram where she is father
see you guys
[Music]